so she absolutely provides value to an
audience she provides entertainment it
provides inspiration for a lot of women
I think she provides a lot of like
self-acceptance because she just kind of
like is unapologetically herself which I
think is pretty clear from her content a
lot of people who watch my stuff are in
business or want to be in business and
so they just think anything that's not
business is not valuable but the vast
majority of entertainers have
significantly higher followings and it's
because more people get value from their
stuff people are willing to pay 1500 to
go and sit in nosebleeds at a Taylor
Swift concert and don't want to pay 500
to go to a real estate convention and a
lot of people actually aren't trying to
get into that game and so the only thing
that they value is just in some ways
escape from the game they're in you
can't educate but for most people
entertainment in and of itself is more
valuable which is why Kylie can build a
bigger audience than somebody who might
just be an educator